I just caught Grandmaster Irina Crush
after a beautiful win today Irina how do
you feel another looking game yeah I
feel pretty good about this game I mean
I think it was
cleaner than I even expected right I
mean at some point I realized I was in
control but you know there were a few
moves in the middle game where I wasn't
so sure what was going on but it looks
like it was yeah like really clean from
start to finish and I think my even my
technique was quite decent
um in the end game like where I didn't
like take this Pawn on e4 right away or
it's kind of improved my Rooks and then
this moved B4 which is pretty cool so
there were some nice touches in this
game and it feels good to get things
back on track I know you had the tough
middle of the tournament can you tell us
about how you're trying to get over
tough losses and you know find your
mindset to fight
yeah it's not it's not easy uh you know
I scored half out of three like in the
middle half middle third I guess of the
event and I certainly felt very bad
yesterday about the kind of um
game that I lost to Alexandra
um you know because I felt like I had
such a comfortable position with very
little risk at all and and I managed to
just
you know play that out to a loss like
you know even had somebody I think so
many chances to defend better
um but anyway so having lost that I was
really quite dejected and I think the
one thing that I did I was talking to my
coach and I was saying like Okay what
should I do to feel better so I like
watched some Netflix show and he's like
no no certainly not you know go outside
go out you know you gotta get outside
and take a walk okay and you know and I
and I dragged myself out to Forest Park
um and it was very beautiful and I you
know somehow on that walk like
my mindset started to change you know
like instead of being this kind of
dejected
self-pitying thing it kind of like it
changed and um and I got back into my
fighter mode like and um and basically I
think that's the power of obedience you
know like that wasn't my idea but I did
what my coach said and uh I think it
helped me turn things around that's uh
very nice to say that because oftentimes
it is difficult for a lot of players to
come back some players don't come back
after a tough loss in a tournament and
then unfortunately if you put that in
your subconscious I think you really
won't come back and it's an important
lesson for a lot of people to
kind of find a way through it I usually
don't approach you after you lose
because I know I don't myself don't like
to be approached after losing a game but
um
I myself like I said it's bad so I
prefer not to be approached I think
everyone kind of needs to internalize
the the relationship with themselves
after the loss and then come back I mean
probably everyone at this tournament
takes losing very hard you know I think
so
um but you know I'm certainly one of
those people and it's not it's not so
easy when you start with two and a half
out of three and then go half out of
three and then to somehow find it in
yourself to like you know feel like
things can get better again you know but
we've had some Inspirations here you
know like Bella starting with half out
of two and then winning like three in a
row and she completely turned her no I
think she started with zero zero out of
two zero yeah and now she's she won her
other fourth game or something four in a
row yeah so she yeah she just kind of
shows that it's possible you just gotta
sit down and play really you know that's
the thing it's not like I was you know
like I had some kind of mentality where
I must win like I don't know I just
played what the position allowed me to
do today it turned out that you know
that was enough and I was able to play a
decent game
that's that's great to hear it was a
nice game so we're yeah I think I'll be
pretty happy with this one you know it's
not that often that you can basically
make it so clean from start to finish
you know
that's right
I had another question for you and
that's regarding your hobbies things
that you like to do I've heard you say
that you like to do various exercise uh
or reading but I wanna I wanna hear it
from you again yeah wow definitely I
like walking you know I walk so much
here like I don't know at least an hour
a day I kind of have co-opted Yasser
into that so you know um he's been my
companion for a lot of these walks in
the evening
um yeah definitely some kind of exercise
like sort of Pilates style things I like
to do reading yes lots of books learning
I guess my main interest in in general
my main hobby is learning right so it
could be like one of the things that I
um put in a lot of time in recently is
Health you know nutrition Health like
all kinds of
exercise
um those things I've you know I've
watched a lot of podcasts on
and I think you mentioned to me one time
that you like to listen to podcasts
oftentimes as you're walking that way
you're killing two birds exactly
well now I listen to Yasser instead of
the podcast but you know what's funny I
just realized I want one I started a
podcast it's like um kind of like a
tutorial on Brazilian Jiu Jitsu you know
so I I'm looking at this and I'm like I
think I'm going to need a partner you
know to practice these moves with
you people are taking back things
yeah it's kind of self-defense I mean I
think that would be very interesting to
learn I think actually if you told me
like the things that I would like to
spend more time on it would be like
dance and Hip Hop I would like to go
back to dance lessons and um and
learning yeah Jujutsu sounds pretty good
to me okay now that you said dance and
Heap I gotta ask you I believe you did
one time
uh a recording of uh rap song are you
still into would you be doing something
like that yeah like no wow well if you
want to write me a rap lyrics you know
um we we can do that again like I mean
I'd be up for it you know if someone
wanted to do that but like yeah I'm not
exactly a writer uh you know Lyricist
myself okay but you would sing it yeah
okay
something else for those of you who
haven't checked yeah I'm writing your
wrap guys give me the song to do it too
and I will do my best okay that's great
is there anything else you would like to
let us know about yourself you're gonna
have something that people don't know or
already you were kind of
famous and popular but maybe there's
still something you'd like people to to
know about yourself oh to know about
myself
wow you know
that's a question there's a lot that's
like what do I want to reveal you know
okay but you know just come up with some
questions guys and I will answer them
all right so let's let's do it that way
let's not you know let's make people
work for it yeah you can't give up
everything right away right yes I agree
yeah I agree right now well as always
it's a pleasure talking to you I'm gonna
let you got two more games you gotta
focus on so I'm Gonna Let You Go yeah
Saturday so I'm going to church or
church first church first then hopefully
some walk and preparation for last year
yes good luck here right now